hey guys George camel here I'm outside
of a Waffle House in Antioch Tennessee
in just a few minutes we're going to
cover everyone's Tab and bless the
weight staff with $500 each and on top
of that one special person is going to
get something extra so let's go in and
show them some outrageous
[Music]
generosity hey guys quick announcement
I'm here on behalf of Ramy Solutions and
we're going to cover all your tabs today
Merry
Christmas cheers Merry Christmas it's on
us
cuz you're amazing is amazing here's
$500 for you Britney thank you so much
thank you well Crosby Merry Christmas
man here's $500 on behalf of Ramy
Solutions wow God bless all right Ross
Merry Christmas $500 on behalf of Ramy
Solutions there's no better feeling than
giving away money we always say that
giving is the most fun you can have with
money and so I want to encourage you
guys you go give give a little until you
can give a lot go bless some people
that's the spirit of the holidays God
bless and Merry Christmas from Ramsey
Solutions